[Musique]
avec nous à lincou chaud comment
allez-vous fort soyez le bienvenu voilà
il a eu un petit accident en sortant sur
la mairie il a une jambe qui le fait
souffrir ça va aller sur le plateau tout
va bien voilà c'est des risques du
métier je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller départemental dans le canton
de mulhouse 1 vous êtes également
adjoint au maire de mulhouse et ce soir
on va partir chez vous dans votre canton
mulhouse 1 c'est le 10e canton du jura
c'est un des rares qui est presque
totalement inclus dans la ville de dans
l'arrondissement de mulhouse et on a
suivi votre binôme catherine rap qui est
avec nous qui vous accompagnent ce soir
relate l suivi sur le terrain regarder
mulhouse 25e agglomérations urbaines de
france rayonne par delà les frontières
alsaciennes de par son art et son
histoire l'arrondissement de mulhouse
comprend 80 communes réparties sur huit
cantons
cette semaine visitent du canton de
mulhouse 1 en compagnie de catherine rap
conseillère départementale
la famille était le pilier de la
campagne des deux conseillers aux
élections de 2015 mulhouse 1 dispose de
quatre collèges de plusieurs groupes
scolaires ainsi que d'un campus
universitaire important le collège bel
air accueille depuis la rentrée 2013 ses
500 élèves dans un tout nouvel
établissement financé en partie par le
conseil départemental du haut rhin c'est
très important que les élèves puissent
étudier dans de bonnes conditions et
donc le collège bel air était un collège
très vétuste où les conditions de
l'enseignement n'était vraiment plus
satisfaisant donc il était important que
nos enfants nos collégiens puissent
étudier dans des conditions vraiment
satisfaisante c'est un tout nouveau
bâtiment aux normes bbc qui a été
entièrement repensée avec vraiment des
économies d'énergie un collège à la
pointe des nouvelles technologies
l'avenir se dessine aussi à partir du
passé mulhouse et fort d'un âge
industriel textile important de
nombreuses usines ont permis à la
commune de rayonner mondialement et de
faire partie de l'excellence au fil des
années les établissements se sont vidés
aujourd'hui le conseil départemental
investi dans ces anciennes friches
industrielles mulhouse 1 veut s'offrir
un lifting et montrer son nouveau visage
tourné vers l'avenir et les nouvelles
technologies à l'image du nouveau pôle
numérique k1n0 ici un doigt de venir
s'implanter la cité du numérique à
mulhouse ça va s'appeler donc qu'à m 0km
0 comme le premier kilomètre d'une voie
ferrée qui est partait à l'époque pour
bâle donc ici vont s'implanter des start
up des écoles du numérique vraiment une
nouvelle vie pour mulhouse tourné vers
le futur le lien entre l'industrie du
passé et la cité du numérique pour le
futur avec à la clé sans doute au moins
2000 emplois sur le site une future
silicon valley à mulhouse 1 c'est bien
ce que souhaitent devenir le canton en
marge de ce développement économique le
conseil départemental investit aussi
dans la culture le fleuron industriel de
la ville l'ancien site dmc fondée en
1846 veut lui aussi renaître de ses
cendres
75 hectares de bâtiments industriels
endormi attendent d'être à nouveau
habité moto qu était la première
association à s'installer sur le site
motoko qui s'est implantée sur ce fameux
bâtiment 75 un collectif d'artistes qui
on a donné un peu les clés qui au sont
venus ici en pleine effervescence
proposé aux mulhousiens des spectacles
leur art sculpteurs peintres musiciens
il se passe plein de choses dans ce
bâtiment 75 c'est une première pierre
ici sur le site et puis viendront
d'autres 1 au milieu de tous ces
bâtiments de venir ici le renouveau ne
nous est en marche le quartier dmc
souhaite aujourd'hui être reconnu pour
sa valeur patrimoniale
la ville de mulhouse candidate pour le
label iba basel bâtir pour l'avenir la
belle dont dispose déjà motoko pour son
bâtiment 75
voilà la couche au conseil départemental
est notre invité quelles sont les
actions pour vous et les priorités du
conseil départemental sur ce canton la
briqueterie rap notre priorité c'est la
famille la famille c'est l'éducation
nous avons quatre collèges sur le canton
c'est aussi les aider avec deux
établissements pour personnes âgées et
puis on s'intéresse également au cadre
de vie avec des interventions des
copropriétés des coteaux avec une
diagonale vers qui va relier la plaine
de l'ill au site du musée de l'auto
l'ensemble de ce que nous souhaitons
fait et puis evans ivan qui évidemment
l'accompagnement à l'innovation au
développement de la ville avec en lien
avec l'achat l'industrie ancien fleuron
de la ville de mulhouse renaît de ses
cendres aujourd'hui pourquoi c'est
important pour vous c'est important
d'abord parce que l'emploi c'est une
priorité de concitoyens et l'idée sur ce
km 0 c'est de créer un véritable
écosystème avec des pme des start up une
école qui va donner une deuxième chance
aux élèves et puis également un thé clab
avoir un véritable système autour du
numérique et pour créer des emplois dans
la dans la ville c'est une bonne idée
d'avoir réhabilité on voit sur ces
images c'est vois la magnifique mulhouse
1 c'est aussi l'enseignement avec les
groupes scolaires avec le campus
universitaire vous investissez dans
l'enseignement ou proposer des solutions
à la pointe de la technologie
c'est pourquoi pour donner aux jeunes
générations tous les outils on va dire
des de l'éducation oui d'abord parce que
c'est une compétence du département on a
quatre collèges qui ont les uns les
autres été rénovés ou vont l'être comme
on l'a vu sur sur votre reportage que
les jeux vion qui va également être dans
la liste de priorités et puis quand on
tournait dans un bon cadre de
fonctionnement de vie on travaille mieux
et puis on est en équipe également ses
élèves en tablette numérique une
expérience qui se fait également à
mulhouse préparer les collégiens au
monde de demain je disais tout à l'heure
ce collège bel air formidable ah c'est
un endroit magnifique et l'équipe
éducative avec mardi fait un travail
remarquable
on observe que les résultats
s'améliorent que l'absentéisme diminue
comme quoi on travaille bien dans des
beaux endroits oui c'est sûr c'est tout
cela que vous avez également inaugurer
ce qu'on appelle du coworking dans votre
canton expliquez-nous ce que c'est à
quoi ça sert c'est un espace où les
travailleurs nomades les créateurs
d'entreprises des auto entrepreneurs
peuvent sortir de leur isolement se
retrouver autour d'une table
participez à travailler ensemble de leur
côté il ya des réseaux qui se crée avec
des liens qui se développent et ça
permet aussi de d'encourager le
développement économique autour de la
ville c'est quoi une sorte de petite
cuisine numérique ou ceux qui ont une
activité peut être chez eux peuvent se
réunir dans ces espaces de coworking
tout à fait il ya une grande table où
les petites alcôves on peut soit
s'isoler pour travailler soit se mettre
autour à plusieurs sur un projet et ça
permet comme ça de faire des rencontres
au hasard des réservations et c'est un
espace qui est ouvert à tous il suffit
de réserver dans l'idéal faire de votre
canton une sorte de d'endroits de
technologies de pointe c'est dans les
tuyaux en tout cas ici mais sûr on a la
présence de l'université dans ce canton
donc c'est un atout de taille pour
pouvoir être à la pointe en termes de
développement alors quand il ya eu ces
élections départementales il ya eu des
binômes qui ont été créés comment ça se
passe et une question que je pose assez
régulièrement aux conseillers
départementaux comment ça se passe avec
votre binôme remarquablement bien on est
parfaitement complémentaire avec
catherine rap on a des bureaux qui sont
proches on se parle tout le temps et
on est totalement interchangeables
m'accompagner si ce soir et franchement
ça se passe remarquablement bien c'est
un vrai plaisir de travailler catherine
voilà vous êtes vous arrivé encore à
marcher tout va bien tout va pour
combien de temps la six semaines ouais
bah là le pauvre il s'est fait mal merci
en tout cas c'était un plaisir de vous
recevoir on a fait comme ça ce petit
tour des cantons duo a